me aparece el Primer Ministro pakistaní
inbram Khan tras el atentado que sufrió
el 3 de noviembre su mensaje profundiza
la división política anunció que no
participará en una marcha programada en
islamabad
cancelé la marcha porque sabía que si
decidíamos llevar a cabo una protesta al
día siguiente podría haber un
derramamiento de sangre
la locución contó con fuertes medidas de
seguridad según la policía unos 10.000
efectivos la custodiaron Cana ha estado
celebrando manifestaciones en todo el
país para presionar unas elecciones
anticipadas bajo el argumento de que fue
derrocado ilegalmente en abril el Primer
Ministro Jack shariff con la ayuda del
gobierno de Estados Unidos desestiman
las acusaciones y se mantienen convocar
las elecciones para 2023 en brancan
afirmó que su partido
abandonará todas las asambleas
regionales y nacionales este colectivo
opositor fue el más votado y ya había
dejado la legislatura lo que en un limbo
las elecciones parlamentarias del jefe
de estado lo que esperamos de emiram es
que pueda traer la verdadera libertad no
hay ningún líder después de quite easam
que pueda traer la verdadera libertad la
libertad intelectual y la libertad
financiera
el gobierno de sanación islámica de 220
millones de habitantes y dotada de armas
nucleares nombró al antiguo jefe de
inteligencia de Khan sabieta sin munir
como nuevo jefe militar una figura que
solo se quedó ocho meses bajo el mandato
de Kant